hola qué tal estoy muy feliz porque
estamos empezando una nueva sección la
sección número 8 del examen número 4 que
por cierto es la última sección de este
examen así que empecemos vamos a hacer
el problema número uno el problema
número uno que dice sí tres por n
cuatros y tres por n 4 esto es lo mismo
que 18 entonces cuánto vale n entonces
cuánto vale n okey pues qué te parece si
resolvemos esta ecuación no está tan
difícil lo único que hay que hacer es
resolver esta ecuación y se me ocurre
que voy a poder dividir todo entre 3
todo entre 3 todo entre 3 de tal manera
que este 3 y este 13 van y me queda que
en menos 4 esto es igual a 18 entre 3 lo
cual es 6 o dicho de otra manera de aquí
podemos concluir que n es igual am y si
sumo cuatro de ambos lados de esta
ecuación me queda en e igual a 10
perfecto
10 que es justo lo que quería y es la
solución de mi primer problema de esta
sección número 8 así que vamos a hacer
el problema número 2 el problema número
2 que dice para comprar un anillo de
graduación cada alumno puede elegir
entre cuatro piedras y tres metales
entonces cada alumno puede elegir entre
cuatro piedras cuatro piedras
y a su vez tres metales y a su vez tres
metales metales ok esto para hacer su
anillo cuántas combinaciones distintas
se pueden hacer de estos anillos bueno
pues este problema es muy fácil las
combinaciones totales es la
multiplicación de 4 por 3 es decir 12 12
combinaciones totales se pueden hacer de
estos anillos 12 combinaciones se pueden
hacer de estos anillos ya que podemos
elegir cada metal con cada una de estas
cuatro piedras preciosas está la
respuesta es 12 y por cierto este es el
inciso de el cis tótem y vamos a hacer
el problema número 3 espero que me quepa
por aquí dice la suma de 3 a la suma de
3 am con la raíz cuadrada de b con la
raíz cuadrada de ba3 a le voy a sumar la
raíz cuadrada de b
esto es igual a la suma de accumbens l
al cuadrado esto dice que es igual a la
suma de convent elevado al cuadrado
además ven esto elevado al cuadrado esta
suma elevado al cuadrado
dice que ecuación representa
matemáticamente esta afirmación guau
pues ya está
de hecho las soluciones esta misma esta
es la solución de este problema que por
cierto es el inciso b lo único que
tenemos que hacer era entender la
oración y ponerla en un lenguaje
matemático pero ya está no te confíes
recuerda que al principio están los
problemas muy sencillos y después los
problemas se empiezan a complicar así
que no te confíes no cambies de vídeo
porque en cualquier momento los
problemas se van a empezar a complicar
así que vamos a abordar la pantalla para
hacer el problema número 4 el problema
número 4 que voy a poner por aquí
carlos tiene un receptor de teléfono
inalámbrico el cual puede operar en un
rango de 100 pies
no espera de mil pies de la base del
teléfono
imagínate que aquí está carlos déjame
cambiar de color para hacerlo más
entretenido carlos tiene un receptor
nuevo y imagínate que aquí está la base
de este receptor aquí está la base de
este receptor y este receptor tiene un
rango de mil pies eso quiere decir que
1000 pies la redonda este teléfono sirve
así que déjame hacer
un círculo por aquí y estoy hablando de
1000 pies la redonda por lo tanto la
distancia que hay de aquí a cualquier
punto de este círculo son 1000 pies o
este radio son 1000 mil pies mil pies ok
ahora date cuenta que en cualquier punto
de este círculo carlos va a obtener una
buena recepción en su teléfono si se
pasa este círculo carlos no va a tener
recepción en su teléfono perfecto y
después dice carlos toma el teléfono de
la base va a descolgar el teléfono y
camina 800 piezas al norte
dónde está el norte para arriba va a
caminar 800 pies no puede caminar hasta
acá porque serían mil pies entonces va a
caminar un poquito menos de 1000 pies
algo como por aquí aquí va a llegar
carlos que son 800 piezas y que deben
ponerlo a son 800 pies 800 pies también
a 800 piezas el norte se para justo aquí
y después camina al este y se detiene en
el último punto en donde puede recibir
señal camina hacia el este déjenme
cambiar de color camina hacia el este
norte sur este y oeste norte sur este y
oeste es para acá va a caminar hacia el
este todo lo que pueda hasta seguir
obteniendo señal es decir que se va a
parar justo aquí en este punto se va a
parar este carlos porque después de este
punto ya no va a obtener señal justo
aquí está parado carlos con su teléfono
muy bien y nos preguntan en qué
dirección puede seguir caminando carlos
en qué dirección puede seguir caminando
carlos de tal manera que siga en el
rango de la señal es decir caminamos
hacia el norte primero caminamos hacia
el norte después caminamos hacia el este
hasta pararnos hacia el este hasta
pararnos en el último punto en donde
podemos obtener señal para dónde podemos
caminar de tal manera que sigamos
teniendo señal buenos y ahora estamos
parados justo aquí y ahora estamos
parados justo aquí date cuenta que no
podemos caminar hacia el norte no
podemos caminar hacia el norte porque
entonces no obtendríamos señal esto no
puede ser posible o no
de hecho déjenme bajarlo con esto esto
no puede ser posible esto no puede ser
posible
tampoco podemos seguir caminando hacia
el este porque si caminamos hacia el
este ya no estamos en el rango de la
señal nos salimos del rango de la señal
por lo tanto no podemos caminar hacia el
este pero si podemos caminar hacia el
sur si podamos que hablar es el sur de
hecho si caminamos hacia el sur
obtenemos todavía señal y también de
igual manera podemos caminar hacia el
oeste es decir que si nosotros queremos
seguir
teniendo señal de este teléfono
solamente podemos caminar hacia el sur
hacia el sur o hacia el oeste hacia el
oeste de este punto de aquí entonces la
respuesta es 2 y 3 que es sur y oeste
oeste que por cierto es el inciso en 2 y
3 es el inciso lema y ya está
tengo la solución del problema número 4
así que vamos a hacer el problema número
5 este problema estuvo muy bien muy bien
oops no no esto tengo que quitar esto
tengo que poner de color negro perfecto
y ahora si problema número 5 el problema
de 15 dice si x x entre 4 es igual a 2x
entre am cuánto vale
cuanto vale a muy bien
y lo primero que se me ocurre es que
podemos dividir de ambos lados entre x
es decir yo puedo dividir este lado
entre xy me va a quedar un cuarto y
también de este lado lo puedo difícil
entre xy me va a quedar 2 sobre a es
decir como x está multiplicando de ambos
lados la puedo eliminar puedo eliminar
esta x y puedo eliminar esta x y me
queda que un cuarto es igual a 2 entre a
y de aquí de aquí ya está muy fácil
porque para obtener el valor de amd
puedo multiplicar cruzado
puedo pasar este para acá y este para
acá es decir como una regla de tres y me
va a quedar que es igual a 2 por 4 lo
cual es 8 a es 8 10 el inciso a es el
inciso am y ya está así que creo que
aquí me cabe perfecto el problema número
6 que dice tengo rectas paralelas vamos
a dibujar aquí mis rectas paralelas
tengo una recta por aquí
y bueno de hecho tú no sabes que esta
recta es paralela a otras y solamente
dibujo esta recta pero ya te puedes
imaginar más o menos el dibujo tengo
esta recta y esta recta de por aquí ok
son paralelas así que me que va a quedar
algo así y después tengo una recta que
las cruza una recta por aquí muy bien y
me dicen que esta recta se llama l esta
recta se llama l mientras que esta se
llama m ésta se llama en mente este
ángulo se llama r éste se llama s este
se llama t rst y éste se llama a ok y me
dicen que el valor de r r vale 50 grados
el valor de r son 50 grados y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale es más de más 1
lo que quiero saber es cuánto es ese más
tema azul y bueno a este problema está
muy fácil lo único que hay que hacer es
recordar que pasa cuando tenemos dos
rectas paralelas y las cruza una
transversal o dicho de otra manera jugar
el juego
hablemos de ángulos correspondientes
este ángulo es correspondiente a este
otro este ángulo y este ángulo son
iguales estás de acuerdo si nosotros
tenemos una recta y la cruza otra recta
entonces estos dos ángulos son iguales
pero como estas dos rectas son paralelas
eso quiere decir que este ángulo también
es igual a 50 grados y este ángulo este
también va a ser igual a 50 grados
por lo tanto déjame ponerlo con el mismo
color este ángulo vale 50 grados y este
también vale 50 grados ahora cómo
podemos obtener el valor de t lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que estos
dos ángulos son suplementarios y usos
suplementarios porque forman un ángulo
de 180 grados estos dos son ángulos
de 180 grados porque están sobre la
misma recta eso quiere decir que temas u
es igual a 180 o dicho de otra manera te
vale 130 grados 130 grados de tal manera
que 130 grados más 50 grados me de 180
grados y ahora sí sistema sur son 180
grados
quedar 50 180 grados lo cual es igual a
230 grados 230 grados es la solución de
este problema número 6 el cual por
cierto es el inciso a la respuesta a
este problema es el inciso am así que
vamos a hacer el problema siguiente
volvemos esto de aquí necesito borrar
toda la pantalla y ya está tengo aquí en
una pantalla nueva un pizarrón nuevo el
vamos a ser el problema número 7 el
problema número 7 que dice y bueno si no
recuerdas todo esto de los ángulos de
las rectas paralelas sería muy bueno que
repasará todo ello en mis vídeos de
geometría en mi sección de geometría de
khan academy
pero bueno regresemos al problema número
7 y dice en el plano x 100 déjame
dibujar aquí el plano x ya de una vez el
plano xy este va a ser mi eje de leyes
por acá va a estar mi
de las x
mientras x más o menos así y voy a poner
que este es el eje y este es el eje x y
dice en el plano x la recta l pasa por
el punto 5 menos tres y es perpendicular
al eje y y eso es importante vamos a ver
dónde está el punto 5 - 3 el punto 5
como a menos ustedes está por aquí si
este es el valor de 5 a déjame cambiar a
esto si este es el valor de 5 y este por
acá es el valor de menos 3 de menos tres
entonces el punto 5 común menos 3 está
por aquí ok y tengo una recta que va a
pasar por ese punto pero además que es
perpendicular al eje i
perpendicular al eje y así que va a
pasar algo como por aquí y de una manera
perpendicular al eje james ok bueno este
punto debería estar un poco más abajo
vamos a ponerlo a este punto está aquí
ok y es perpendicular al eje y es decir
que forma un ángulo de 90 grados
esta es una recta l muy bien dice cuál
de las siguientes ecuaciones
es una ecuación para la recta el ok
vamos a ver este es el punto cinco coma
menos tres es decir que nosotros
queremos obtener la ecuación de la recta
l pues primero sería muy bueno saber
cuál es su pendiente la pendiente de la
recta l quién es bueno pues es el cambio
y james a comparación del cambio en x es
decir la elevación entre el avance pero
si te das cuenta
esta es una recta constante para
cualquier valor que nosotros corramos en
x el valor en yemen siempre va a ser el
mismo por lo tanto si hablamos del
cambio en james a comparación del cambio
en x pues esto es lo mismo que el cambio
en james pero no cambiamos el bien
siempre tenemos la misma altura por lo
tanto va a ser cero entre lo que sea no
importa cero entre lo que sea lo cual es
cero por lo tanto la pendiente de esta
recta es cero es decir que si queremos
la ecuación de esta recta la ecuación es
igual a m x + b ya podemos ir
sustituyendo algunas cosas
es igual a m pero m vale 0 a 0 por x 0
por x + b pero ve es decir justo aquí al
valor en donde cortamos elegir leyes que
por cierto es menos 3 entonces en lugar
de más aquí va a ser menos 3 por lo
tanto esta recta tiene como ecuación la
ecuación y es igual 0 por x estos se van
y es igual a menos 3 y esta es la
solución de este problema y es igual a
menos 3 porque es una recta constante
para cualquier valor que nosotros nos
tomemos en x 10 siempre va a valer menos
3 - 3 - 3 - 3 y de hecho cualquier recta
que cruce al eje de las 10 de forma
perpendicular va a tener como ecuación y
igual a una constante y bueno este es el
inciso c el inciso sem y ya está aquí la
solución de este problema y ya casi no
tengo tiempo tengo algo de tiempo pero
tengo el tiempo contado así que no me
gustaría entrometerme en un nuevo
problema y hacerlo
de manera muy rápida o amontonar las
cosas así que creo que sería mucho mejor
dejar por aquí este vídeo y nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo para hacer más
problemas de la sección número 8 del
examen número 4 así que en el siguiente
vídeo continuamos con el problema número
8 hasta la próxima